new call of duty trailer everybody and
crispy crispy 4k it's actually in a
really weird resolution
um so i just put black bars on the
bottom and top
uh i'm excited to watch this trailer but
i also just always really like the
worldwide uh
i guess they call them world gameplay
reveal trailers that come out for call
of duty virtually every year i've always
tried to keep up with them because i
feel like the trends that cod takes as a
franchise that was at the very top and
has now actually plateaued a little bit
it's just very interesting to watch i
think they're interesting decisions um
it's just such a
an industry juggernaut that's seeing
what changes they make and why
it's always kind of an idea of where
they predict as an activision might
predict that the uh industry trends lie
right now and i don't know it's
interesting to see um obviously they're
coming off of
a game that uh was not tremendously
popular being vanguard compared to
previous years so a lot riding on this
one i was a fan of modern warfare and
one warfare 2 way back in the day i like
the 2019 modern warfare a lot more than
i feel like some of the other directions
that call of duty is going in um so i'm
interested to see where this is and if
they add you know weird rifle skins and
dubstep or if it seems a bit more
grounded so watch the trailer in any
case
and then um after that
i might catch up on some of the news
because there seems like there was an
influencer event that a bunch of people
went to as well so let's check it out
it's a very interesting way to start
that's cool
who do we
send hell yeah
this is so moody
all right that's where we're in
positions
[Music]
they're so good at making trailers
anywhere i
this is very cool
but i will say
doesn't look as graphically impressive
as i expected for whatever reason
it's super well edited
a lot of action
very cool very very very cool trailer 28
yeah nice
and get early access to the open beta
you just want to see this opening again
that's so rad it's so cool it's a very
cool trailer yeah just some of them like
i always judge uh trailers on the way
that water looks and i will say
this part right here
um
where you can see
you know just like the fake
like water just rising upwards um just
always kind of stands out to me trying
to
cover the i just had surgery so
apologies if you can see
the scar that's on the top of my head
i'll
leave a link in the description or
whatever to
why basically the answer is migraines
but i have a big old uh wound on the top
of my head um sorry if you saw that
don't want to gross anybody out
yeah i just why would water do that when
you would raise up from it i don't know
i also tend to judge video games on fire
like if their fire looks 2d is it just a
little 2d asset but
no it does look very good overall uh
let's read some comments shall we i
think that this is probably
going to be pretty well received for the
trailer mining this trailer actually
wasn't overboard it was perfect and felt
like with this trailer they're returning
back to what made them so successful
i'm in agreement i think this is
probably what people want right this is
more in line with the call of duty that
people want
um and it seems like they've recognized
that yeah people are more excited about
warfare game for sure
please allow the multiplayer lobbies to
stay together after games bring back the
old oh that's true
oh that would be rad i doubt it though
i'll be buying this just for the
campaign oh
okay
oh
just for the campaign alone i hope to
see more missions like clean house those
were the highlights of the game in my
opinion excited for the acr and
hopefully we see the og intervention no
other game franchise can make you
believe in it each year if i'm let down
previously like
it does seem wow this is
these are very like
good bots
like
i don't i probably shouldn't might get
demonetized for even looking at them but
those are detailed bots
jules there is one thing called duty is
always able to do and that is create
amazing trailers i agree this is a very
good trailer they they do put a lot of
hype into them
no jet packs no bright pink rifles looks
amazing i hope the campaign lives up to
the previous one yeah it is it
definitely seems a lot more like what
what people want so let's catch up on
some news
alrighty we are on the verge here
who said it's no secret that infinity
ward has been working on a sequel to
2019's call of duty modern warfare and
now the studio is finally unveiling its
next blockbuster it's called modern
warfare 2 and it features both a
single-player campaign that's a direct
sequel to the previous game okay i mean
it makes sense
uh i just didn't know that for sure so
first the campaign here's how infinity
ward describes the setup modern warfare
2 picks up the action as a sequel to
modern warfare as the newly formed task
force 141 faces a massive global threat
across a campaign of missions
that push the boundaries of gameplay the
action takes players around the world as
task force 141 works to neutralize a
terrorist conspiracy an attack on the us
banning locations around the globe a
newly aligned menace conspires to create
chaos inside the us's borders and task
force one for one must come together
against all odds
players will fight alongside the most
iconic characters in modern warfare
including captain price ghost soap gaz
and laswell
as well as encounter a host of lethal
new allies like mexican special forces
coal colonel
you really got to read that whole word
to pronounce it correctly alejandro
vargas and adversaries drawn from the
murkiest corners
of the global war on terror given the
current state of the world with an
ongoing war in ukraine and a sudden
focus on gun violence in the us one wolf
at
all right
in a preview for press ahead of the
announcement infinity war closed studio
had patrick kelly explained we're
telling fictional stories but it is
inspired by real world military events
that shape the world we live in
i find this very strange
i don't know maybe this is like a maybe
i need to think more about this opinion
before sharing it but it seems very
weird to me that video games are so
frequently
asked
to answer for real world events
when other industries aren't
like
like it's modern warfare you know what
it is
and they're always going to give the
same answer why ask them about ukraine i
don't know it just seems weird uh
someone has a sensitive one for me
because with the events going on in the
world the war on ukraine it's important
to me that we'd be sensitive on this one
okay
he explained that one of the goals was
to present the kim's characters heroic
but also human his philosophy appears to
be a change from the previous modern
warfare which tended to more
sensationalist depictions of war
appreciate that don't want propaganda
multiplayer meanwhile will feature both
large-scale maps for lots of players
simultaneously the studio says it
learned a lot from
making the dance map for the battle
royal call of duty war zone as well as
smaller ones designed for six v6 matches
there's also what the studio describes
as an evolved special ops game mode
featuring tactical co-op gameplay that
sounds cool
as part of its official reveal of modern
warfare 2 activision also reiterated
that call of duty warzone would be
coming to mobile it's going to do well
for them
there isn't much else in the way of
details such as when it will launch or
how it will differ from the console and
pc version but the publisher says the
mobile war zone is part of a new era for
the franchise that includes a number of
developments like utilizing the same
engine across modern warfare 2 and the
next iteration of war zone that's due to
launch later this year as well as
treating the new warzone experience as
an extension of the modern warfare 2
universe that's interesting
uh october 28th marks a new beginning
for call of duty starting with the
release of modern warfare 2 soon after a
wholly new war zone will launch
as an extension of the modern warfare 2
universe with it comes new technology
new features and new gameplay that works
seamlessly together throughout we have
taken a wide range of community feedback
to heart
in order to fully deliver the state of
art experience state of the art
experience sorry
warzone 2.0 will feature new modern
warfare 2 content and systems with brand
new progression and inventories today's
warzone will continue on as a separate
experience that will include a
continuation of player progression and
inventories within that warzone
experience that's cool
it is scheduled to launch on the 28th
for a range of platforms
oh and for the first time in years steam
that's interesting probably a good
choice
um
hey
it's a damn good trailer it looks like
the
what i feel like the quad community has
been asking for and really wants um be
interesting to see if sales reflect that
because i'm never really convinced like
that so much of the conversation
actually translates directly to to sales
or is it just a small very very very
small vocal minority people complaining
um be interesting to see